[موسيقى]
والله العمل بيعنيني اول وحده عمل انساني
لي انه الله سبحانه وتعالى احد البصر
ورزقني البصيره لاكوس من البصر واقوى
البصر الحمد لله رب العالمين شغله
لانه من الدقيقه وهذا يعني
[موسيقى]
عمان
مواليدي 63 عمري 60 سنه والله هجرنا
نجحنا قمنا بمدينه الباب
[موسيقى]
شباب وبنت ثلاثه متزوجين والبنت متزوجه
عندي واحد اعزب لا عنده شغله ولا عندها
عمله والله دائري كمان حتى هني عايشين
بالدين
[موسيقى]
وبنات والحمد لله رب العالمين انا كنت
يعني اشتغلت بالبدايه كنت اعمل قوم اجي
يعني عندي محل قومي انفجر عليه دولاب
سياره ربع لي عينيه صار معي ضمور بالعين
كفيف البصر يعني
والسماء
فيا طاول داليا خمسه بالعشره
اسناني كمان قالوا اسناني
وعلى اسر
باربي بالشغلات هاي صار معي التهاب عصب
وركيسك والله مريض يعني
بكره لانه انا بواريه من تركه زيت الزيتون
يعني بكره الي وللناس اللي بحاجه يعني
بايدهن والله نزلت
بلاستيك حشيته باطون وعملتوا
تنكات زيت من هون
للبيت وعملت باب لانه هو كمان
قناه البواري انا من الدقيقه
جتني ما معي حق بواري اشتري بواري والله
جدتي فكره سبع البواري البورية عبارات زيت
بعد ما افتحه كذا مشان الصوبه مشان نتدفى
عليه ركب النصوبه ونتفق عليهم عرفت شلون
[موسيقى]
وصلت الفكره يعني
الناس اللي بحاجه وما معهم كمان في ناس
كتير بحاجه
ايش بيسووا على البوري بمشي امرك فيه
المعدات اللي بيشتغلوا بيشتغل فيهم بالبيت
فتاح مشغل تحت تنكه هاي تاني وحده في عندي
المطرقه
المنزلي كمان على ايدي والمبرد عوض المقص
مشان
المسامير مشان تمكين البوري عند بعد
وركبهم مضبوط
[موسيقى]
يعني صعب شوي علي بصير بجربه
بيطلع منه دم من هون من هون
بصير حتى الشفره يعني
[موسيقى]
بحب انا اشتغل شغلتي حتى كمان بايدي
لانه ما بامن حدا مثلا يشتغل لانه مشان
طالع شغله بايدي
وزابطه
92 سم والعرض نفس الشيء اعاده النظامي
البوري النظام ميه بالميه الحمد لله
[موسيقى]